what is the story of science and
scientists doing the rise
rule and fall of the third reich
well we tend to think of science as
always on the side of liberty
as always on the side of
enlightenment is
always on the side of
enlarging
human possibility and here we have this
phenomenon in the 1930s of
really the world's leading scientific
power
the third reich
which collectively had won a big chunk
of all the nobel prizes suddenly they go
fascists they go nazi with hitler
and
instead of being primarily a source of
resistance
science in many respects actually is a
full collaborator
in the most horrific
forms of nazi genocide nazi exclusion
and uh
that's kind of a a relatively untold
story in in the sense that
when we think of science in the third
reich we think of joseph mingley
injecting dye into the eyes of twins or
we think of horrific human experiments
and those are real
but it's also the story of a huge
scientific apparatus a bureaucracy you
could almost say
participating in every phase of the
campaigns of nazi destruction
and what i looked at in particular in in
actually my first book was how
physicians in particular but also
biomedical science
um
was collaborating with the regime and
that
it's wrong to think of the nazi regime
as anti-science
it's anti-a particular type of science
in particular it was radically against
what they call jewish science communist
science
certain types of science they did not
like
there's a whole nature nurture
dispute in that period and they're
firmly on the side of nature
um
which interestingly gives advice to rise
to a very different type of science in
the soviet union by the way the soviet
union is more on the nurture side
the soviet union is on the side of the
nurture side in the
dimension of genetics and this is
sort of an untold story i was actually
going to write a book about it until i
was barred from
access to the soviet union
there have been different times in my
life where i
was a russianist a russianist okay we're
gonna have to talk about that but i got
excluded
from
fulfilling that dream
but one of the things i was going to
look at when i got a fulbright
in the 1980s was to
go over and look at the anti-not
genetics and anthropology of the soviets
and how a lot of their
lysincoast lamarcism was actually
anti-nazi
anti-genetics on the nurture side of
nature and that's really an untold story
it's an uncomfortable story
because it sounds like someone we might
want to make heroes out of some of the
twisting of science in the soviet union
but nonetheless there are these
interesting complexities and
what's amazing about nazi sciences is
how there was this collaboration
and you're talking about
a culture where they're inventing things
like electron microscopy they're doing
all kinds of
studies in anthropology so a lot of
that's an untold story
you